hey everyone i'm john coogan and this is
the first in a series of videos about
fundraising
i thought it would be useful to share
some of my experiences because
as of september 2020 i've been involved
in 10 different financing rounds there's
always an element of luck involved in
fundraising
but there are a few patterns that should
make the whole process a lot less
stressful if you follow them
i'm going to start every video with this
same message the best way to raise money
is to build a great company full stop
you can be absolutely awful at
fundraising
and do everything wrong but if your
company is making its customers happy
growing the customer base significantly
every month and has a giant pool of
potential customers
you will be able to raise money with
ease so before you focus on optimizing
your fundraising process
make sure you have spent orders of
magnitude more time optimizing your core
business
in thinking about fundraising for your
startup the first question you should
always ask yourself is whether or not
you should raise money for your startup
it's very easy to look at funding
announcements for startups and conflate
fundraising success with actual success
although the name of the game in venture
capital is to correlate these two as
closely as possible
the majority of venture capital
investments fail to produce a positive
return
raising money for your company does not
make your company successful
rapid growth is what makes your company
successful rapidly growing companies can
often use outside money to grow faster
and because they are growing so quickly
the process
for raising capital is often very easy
there are plenty of good reasons to
not want to raise money the most obvious
reason is what you give up for that
money
shares in your company if you believe
that your company is already on track to
be worth
billions of dollars and that additional
cash in the bank won't help you get
there
there is little reason to give up 20 or
more of your company
dilution not only affects your financial
return it can have big implications on
control of your company
once the founders own less than half of
the controlling shares
big decisions at the company become much
more complex
the second reason to hold off on raising
money is that it can be a huge
distraction
you can quickly get sucked into calls
coffees and dinners that can take up
most of your workday
this inevitably takes you away from your
most important job
actually growing your company lastly if
you don't believe you can actually
convince
investors to give you money for your
business there's no reason to spend time
fundraising
you won't just waste your time you'll
also hurt your reputation
with that out of the way let's talk
about some of the reasons why you would
want to raise money
the best reason is always that you've
found something that's working and
having extra cash in the bank will help
you scale the business faster
selling shares at an early stage will
dilute the amount that you own
so it better be worth it you need to be
crystal clear on where you will invest
the money within your business once you
have it to maximize growth
another reason lots of companies raise
money is that they simply cannot grow
off of profits alone
it's never good to be in a position
where you need to raise money
because you'll be on your back foot in
most negotiations but it does happen
in this case you should always look at
your business and see if there is a way
to restructure to get to breakeven
so you don't wind up raising money on
onerous terms
sometimes founders feel pressure to
raise money because their competitors
are raising money
this is completely natural since there
is a real threat in some industries
that the most well financed company will
win
the feeling of being second or third
behind a hot competitor with lots of
funding can be disappointing
but highly capitalized companies often
flame out so try not to let it get to
you
there are also other more rare
situations where fundraising can fulfill
a tangential goal
like forming a strategic partnership
with a large incumbent that could lead
to an acquisition
or providing liquidity to founders and
early employees but these funding rounds
usually only happen at the very late
stages of a company
so i'll focus mostly on examples where
your company is growing rapidly and
wants to expand
so once you've decided that raising
money is right for you how do you decide
what your funding target should be
again the best methodology is going to
be based on growth
how much money do you need to grow
aggressively and hit a new major
milestone for the company
you might look at what it will cost to
develop a new product or how much a
sales and marketing push will cost
ideally money invested in user
acquisition will turn into profits
quickly enough
that you won't need to raise a huge
round of financing to hit your growth
targets
but if your customer typically generates
profit for you over a long period of
time
this can be totally worth it internally
you might be looking at your current
burn rate and plan on raising enough
money to cover another year or two of
expenses
that can be a useful metric for managing
the business but it won't get investors
excited
no one wants to invest in a company that
plans on stagnating between rounds
so focus on growth other considerations
that influence how much you raise could
be tied to capital expenditures
r d costs or other industry specific
investments that you plan to make
these are all edge cases that depend on
the type of company you're building
lastly it's good to keep benchmarks in
mind since most investors will have
those in the back of their heads at all
times it's common for most valuations to
be between
five and ten times the amount of money
invested which is why twenty percent
dilution
tends to be a common benchmark for
founders this also varies widely based
on the growth trajectory of the company
and there are always exceptions once
you've decided that it's a good time to
raise money for your startup and you
know what your fundraising target is
the next phase is to figure out who to
raise money from so that will be the
subject of my next video
please hit the subscribe button and
click the bell if you want to be
notified when that video goes live
and if you have any questions or follow
ups that you'd like me to address
please leave me a comment below i try to
reply to every question that i receive
thanks for watching